Welcome.
My name is Kate Hertweck.
I'm the bioinformatics
training manager
at Fred Hutchinson
Cancer Research
Center in Seattle, Washington.
My career focus is helping
scientists learn the coding
and data skills
they need to apply
cutting-edge
computational methods
and accelerate the
rate of science.
I'm excited to
tell you about one
of the best parts of my job--
helping researchers unlock
the mindset and tools
that help them make
the most of their data
and get more work
done in less time.
Here's how the general
process of teaching someone R
usually happens.
I work for a biomedical
research center
with a huge breadth
of research topics.
But everyone wants to make
figures for publication.
My community loves R,
especially tidyverse,
because it makes
sense to them to be
able to achieve those goals.
In my introductory
R class, I start
by teaching some general
skills in data manipulation
and filtering.
My participants learn to
create elegant, effective data
visualizations that help
them explore their data.
After a few hours bent
over their keyboards,
I can see the slowly dawning
realization in their eyes.
With the power
unlocked by coding,
I will surely obtain a
statistically significant
result supporting my
insightful hypothesis,
yielding fame and glory,
but more importantly
a paper in Nature or Science as
well as future grant funding.
In case you're not a
scientist, and this
doesn't resonate
with you, let's think
about it from a layperson's,
well, lay dog's perspective.
For scientists, unlocking
the power of coding
is like when we're dogs getting
a one-way ticket to the dog
park complete with all of
our favorite toys and lots
of interesting things to sniff.
That moment when the dog
realizes the dog park is near
is like that moment when an
important concept about data
or computational work clicks
for someone learning R
and they see a world of
opportunity open up for them.
Unfortunately, all too
often, when the time
comes to apply their
skills to their own data,
they're confronted
with a console
that looks more like this.
These red error messages
are sometimes scary,
often confusing, and
always frustrating.
The prevalent feeling
they experience
is disappointment
tinged with a touch
of how am I supposed to
achieve fame and glory when
I can't even get R to
acknowledge my data exists?
That crushing defeat in
the face of such promise
is also something a
dog can relate to.
It's the equivalent
of jumping in the car,
thinking we're heading
to the dog park.
We can almost feel the
breeze, taste the rubber ball
in our mouth, and
smell the grass,
instead ending up at the vet.
This is exactly the
opposite of what we wanted.
It's disappointing
and demoralizing
so much so that we don't
want to get in the car again,
even if we might end up at the
dog park eventually someday.
So how do we jump
over this barrier,
restoring a belief that we
can achieve those lofty goals?
When I accepted my
current position
to develop and implement
a training program
in reproducible computational
methods 2 and 1/2 years ago,
I thought the most
important part of my job
would be time spent
in a classroom.
I had spent the
previous four years
teaching computational skills
to students at the university
level.
And after an entire
career in academia,
I thought that
the highest impact
I could have at
a research center
would involve teaching formerly
structured short courses.
During my career,
I've had the privilege
of personally teaching
hundreds of people
to code in R. Especially
in my last few years
focusing on adult learners
outside of formal university
courses, I've learned
a lot about what
it takes to help people
succeed in learning R.
And that success is
not solely reliant
on formal short courses.
Now, I define success as
whether people continue
to work with R after
leaving my classroom
or at least if they gain some
general literacy and data
and computing skills so they
can work more effectively
with computational staff.
Given the breadth of research
topics members of my community
pursue, I am faced with
the monumental task
of helping people apply R skills
to many different types of data
and research questions.
The question I then
continually ask myself
as I prepare to deliver
training materials is this.
What prevents people
from using these tools
after they've learned them?
Let's take a quick tour of the
process of gaining expertise
and think about what this
looks like with coding.
Regardless of the
prior education someone
possesses in a
different field, I
consider a person who has
no prior experience learning
to code in R a novice.
In my community, that
means they probably don't
have any experience coding
in a different language
and probably also
don't know much
about how to structure and
store their data effectively.
I integrate general concepts
in coding and data management
into my intro R course and focus
on directly applicable skills
like those I showed
in code earlier.
By the time someone has
completed my introductory R
class, I like to
think that they're
no longer a novice since
they have now transitioned
to competent practitioner.
I define a competent
practitioner as someone
who applies R code to their
own research problems.
A practitioner probably doesn't
know if the way that they code
represents the most elegant
or efficient solution
to a problem.
But they get the job done.
I consider expert-level
coders to be
people who are writing code that
make it easy for other people
to use it.
They encapsulate their projects
in fully documented R packages
and try to apply best
practices in coding to make
it robust and reproducible.
To be clear, I'm less concerned
about formally categorizing
people into these groups.
I think more about
how to help people
follow the arrows to the right.
In practice, most
people I encounter
are practitioners of
some type most often
interested in getting
the immediate job done.
Regardless, this model
is a really useful way
to think about a
few key questions.
What do people need to learn?
And how are they most likely
to learn these things?
We're going to investigate
these questions
by visiting a few colleagues
of mine who generally represent
each of these categories.
Please meet Ash.
Ash is trained in
software engineering
and currently works in data
management and software
development in a research
lab writing software
for scientists to use
for research purposes.
Ash is writing a
package named borkr.
Borkr creates maps
indicating density
of dogs being walked in
certain areas of a city
at certain times.
Ash hopes that borkr will be
used for both public dog health
tracking as well as integration
with the dog social media
network Snootbork.
However, Ash hasn't worked
much with maps lately.
And Ash needs to know the
best approaches in borkr
to achieve their goals.
What Ash does is go and asks
on Twitter and some local Slack
communities for their
recommendations.
They are able to narrow down
the options available based
on what they and their friends
understand about the project
requirements.
Ash goes ahead and references
the relevant documentation
for each option.
And given their
breadth of knowledge,
Ash can quickly identify the
relevant functions and how
to connect them together
to implement mapping
in the context of borkr.
One of his colleagues
is named Avery.
Avery's a graduate student
with some formal coursework
in data science but is still
learning the best methods
for optimizing
workflows in R. Avery
is developing documentation
for a group of summer interns
and wants to streamline the
process of creating projects
with them.
Avery goes and asks
Ash who recommends
the package use this.
Avery is really excited,
goes and takes a look
at the main documentation page,
and is really intimidated.
They haven't worked with a
package like this before.
And they also haven't worked
much with Git or GitHub, which
is one of the really awesome
features involved in use this.
They especially aren't
comfortable in their ability
to use this package and help
other people use the tool as
well.
So Avery comes to my office
hours and asks for help.
I point them towards a project
from our colleagues' lab
that actually applies use this.
This particular
project is a template
that includes working with
GitHub, starting an analysis,
and explaining why their
particular approach works
for data analysis projects.
The explanation Avery
needed didn't just
include the code to run
but an example of how
all the pieces would fit
together in a final project.
Avery's really excited
about this breakthrough
and uses the package to support
their summer intern Quinn.
Quinn is an
undergraduate in biology
who has recently started
learning computational methods.
Quinn thought my intro R
class was quite intuitive
and is eager to apply their
skills to their summer project.
However, they ended
up encountering
the same problem I showed at
the beginning of this talk--
errors associated with read_csv.
Now, Quinn knows how to
use the help function
to share information about it.
And then they encounter
what is, in my opinion,
one of the great
contradictions of computing.
The simpler a function
seems, the more complicated
the help documentation
appears, especially
to someone new to coding.
Quinn's reaction is similar
to the general response
I get from a novice
learner's first glance
at this help documentation--
a bit of abject horror
thinking what have I done.
However, Quinn goes
and talks to Avery,
who helps them think about
the basics of R coding,
the structure of their data, and
how their project is organized,
ultimately helping
them understand
how to piece together
that information
to import their data.
These, of course,
are the problems
with which we all grapple
on a nearly daily basis.
How do we prioritize how to
exert our energy, especially
when we have different goals
with competing interests
and it's not clear whether or
not the effort we're exerting
is going to make a huge
difference in the long run?
These questions include things
like, do I write a vignette
or add a new feature to
the package I'm developing?
Do I keep trying to
get this function
to work for my analysis?
Or do I give up and
try something else?
How do I even find the help I
need to address this key issue?
As it turns out, even
small differences
in how support
materials are developed
can make the difference
between someone struggling
and wrestling with
implementing a new approach
or being able to take
the ball and run with it.
This is because,
in my experience,
learning specific
technical skills is easy.
However, once you've learned
how a technical skill generally
operates, being able to apply
that to your own problem
is much more difficult.
The usefulness
of training and documentation
depends on both what
information is provided
and how it's delivered.
Now that we have an idea
of the problem we face,
how do we actually
meet these needs?
So far, I've made some
generally vague references
to training materials
and documentation.
I think it's worth highlighting
what some of these options
include.
And if you'd like
more information
on detailed descriptions
of types of materials,
head over to the
resources I've included
in RStudio's collection
of conference materials.
First, manuals-- we have
a baseline expectation
in the community that a
standardized user manual
documenting features of
a package is included.
This particular documentation
provides basic information
like how does a
function work and what
options are available for
working with a function.
In my experience, manuals are
most useful for expert users
or people who have some
familiarity with how
the particular type
of function can work.
Another type of
material is vignettes.
Vignettes answer questions like,
how do functions work together
to answer general questions?
These tend to be more
like demos or tutorials
for implementing
code, which ends up
making them much more accessible
for a broad variety of users.
A third type of support material
are example projects or code.
These demonstrate what an
applicable authentic project
incorporating a tool looks like.
And these end up being
very crucial, especially
for practitioners.
Fourth, formerly structured
in-depth short courses
are generally in highest demand
for novices and often something
that most people
are familiar with.
They would like someone to
tell them what the answers are.
Now, each of these
different approaches
requires a different
amount of effort
to both find if you're
wanting to learn from it
or develop if you
are creating it.
And sometimes, these
resources do blend together.
They're also generally
supplemented by conversations
with colleagues,
which I've found
is one of the most valuable
ways to fill in knowledge gaps.
Now that we've considered
how types of support
vary based on levels of
expertise, let's return to Ash.
Ash is excited that their
package is nearing completion.
So they share the manual
with Avery and Quinn.
Avery has trouble understanding
how some of the borkr functions
work but learns a lot
in the process of trying
to figure it out.
Quinn doesn't understand any of
it, including that Ash actually
wrote the package,
and then Quinn
tries to Google it to
find more information.
They come across search results
for a Chinese death metal band
by the same name.
And Ash ultimately regrets
not googling the name
before deciding on
it for their package.
At this point,
Ash has a choice--
continue the package development
to integrate with Snootbork
or make it clearer what the
package is doing right now.
Ash decides to ask
Avery to collaborate
on explaining how
functions fit together more
clearly in a vignette.
They're supported by another
of Ashley's colleagues
who have developed some
code using borkr, which
Ash is happy to reference in the
documentation for the package.
Quinn keeps attending
meetings and learns a lot
about the process of
code collaboration
and eventually even clarifies a
few instructions in the manual.
This story from my
colleagues is one example
of the process of
developing documentation.
What does it mean in
broader practice though?
There are countless online
classes, tutorials, demos,
and other resources
that can help
you learn R. These are
approaches that walk us
through the process
of some coding tasks,
essentially leading
you by a leash.
Given that availability,
why do people
keep coming into my classroom?
What I've learned
really makes or breaks
progression to higher
levels of expertise
is access to information that
helps fill in the biggest
gaps in our knowledge.
My job as a trainer
is to provide guidance
that fills in those gaps, which
allows learners to keep moving
in the same direction
but without a leash
so that they have guidance,
but more importantly, autonomy.
So while I'm developing
support materials,
I consider identifying
what knowledge
is assumed in the
materials I'm developing
as well as collecting
curated examples of code
that apply methods commonly
desired in my community.
In fact, one of the most
effective things we can do
is share high-quality training
materials with the people
for whom they are most suited.
The ecosystem of tools
available in the R community
really reflects the interests
of the people comprising
that community.
With so many tools to
maintain and develop,
is it worth developing and
maintaining support materials
too?
Well, we share our
code so other people
can benefit from our
hard work and to increase
the impact of our efforts.
If sharing our code
results in a multiplier
effect for our
effort, then making
it easier for people to use the
code multiplies it yet again.
At a time when
disparities in the world
feel more stark than ever,
access to information
makes a huge difference
in promoting equity
for developing these skills.
These values are why we
support open science projects.
And that means
considering how even
our small actions can continue
to uphold these values.
In many cases, we don't even
have to create these materials
ourselves.
Knowing what resources exist and
helping raise their visibility
can have a huge impact too.
Regardless of what
level of expertise
you think best describes you,
please consider the following.
For those of us
beginning to code in R,
it's likely we'll encounter
a piece of documentation
we don't understand.
That's OK, and
it's not our fault.
That information
probably isn't written
to be accessible for people
with our type of expertise.
There's almost certainly a
better resource out there
or materials that can
help us bridge that gap.
For those of us who are
practitioners worrying
that even if our code works
it just isn't good enough,
it's OK.
Every expert coder has
been where we are now.
There's also no
requirement that we keep
learning more advanced skills.
But the community
is here to help us.
And it'll probably be
very satisfying to learn.
Finally, those of us who
are experts developing R
packages unsure how to
make the information
accessible to a broad audience--
it's OK.
This is a great
opportunity for us
to collaborate with someone with
a different type of expertise.
These relationships can
help us share our tools
more broadly while supporting
other community members
and advancing their own skills.
For all of us struggling
to communicate with people
who possess different
knowledge and skills, remember,
this is something
everyone confronts.
Given that we're all
continually learning things
and, yes, also forgetting
things periodically,
our own knowledge and
that of those around us
is constantly changing too,
making for a sometimes rapidly
moving target.
One of the best things
we can do for each other
is understand that we
can't expect a resource
to be one size fits all and
that helping someone else learn
is a way of supporting
the entire community
as well as yourself
in the future.
I learned about
the basic framework
of levels of expertise
from The Carpentries.
This nonprofit group teaches
reproducible data and computing
skills, including R, to
communities worldwide and have
a number of resources related
to training diverse audiences
in technical skills.
My current work at Fred Hutch
builds on methods and materials
from The Carpentries.
I've adapted their
workshop content
to directly apply to the
research community I serve.
We otherwise apply the concepts
I've discussed here to training
and community development.
I'm also proud to be
advising MetaDocencia,
group focused on a different
type of targeted community
development, supporting
educational practices
for Spanish-speaking
communities.
And this includes
teaching technical skills.
Each of these groups facilitate
training for diverse audiences
and demonstrate how
even small changes
can mean a lot for individual
learners in the R community.
If you'd like more information
about the ideas I've mentioned
here, check out
the resources I've
included in RStudio's collection
of conference materials.
If you'd like to talk about
computational training
and customizing our resources,
follow me on Twitter.
I can also recommend
my Twitter account
if you'd like to see pictures
of my favorite coworker Loki.
He wouldn't consider himself
to be even a novice R coder.
But he does listen very
intently to all of my thoughts
about training and
community building.
Thanks for watching
and for helping
support a bigger, more
inclusive global R community.